let's bring in former acting ice
director and fox news contributor tom
homan tom let me ask you about the
breaking news first of all
um personnel is often policy right so
the biden administration finally
announcing
who they would like to nominate to run
customs and border protection this is
chris magnus he's a police chief in
tucson arizona
i'm not sure if you're familiar with him
but if you are get your thoughts on that
and filling this position
i'm not familiar with him but if if he's
in law enforcement
it's probably a good thing however if
tucson is still a sanctuary city and he
supports that
i have a huge problem with it so i'd
have to research him more to find out
exactly where he stands in immigration
you can't be running cbp and believe in
sanctuary cities it's ridiculous
all right let's also have you listen to
governor abbott of texas he was on with
fox news sunday yesterday talking about
this number
that is projected 35 000 migrant
children in
federal custody by june watch
and there is a report of the new york
times governor that the
government now projects more than 35
000 unaccompanied minors in federal
custody
by june one could it get that bad and
two what's the biggest single thing
that president biden could do to stop
the surge
first chris i will tell you that
candidly i expect that number to be
far higher so he expects the number to
be higher just for everybody to see at
home let me put the numbers up on the
screen for you
the number of unaccompanied minors
encountered in january was 5852 remember
these are all
kids under the age of 18. in march up to
18
890. so if you do the math perhaps
governor abbott is correct
it would be more than 35 000.
i absolutely think it's going to be
higher look what the buy administration
is doing
they're they're spending billions of
dollars of setting up more welcome
centers
so they can move these migrants through
the process quicker because if they can
if they can prevent overcrowding then
they're going to say it's not a crisis
you know even though thousands are
coming every day being released there's
not a crisis according to them
so they're gonna they're gonna get
really good at releasing people so i
think the numbers of uacs is going to
climb
extraordinarily at extraordinary high
rates but they're going to have billions
of dollars in facilities they're
building
to to get them through the process more
efficiently the bottom line is
why aren't they stopping it you know
spend billions of dollars of taxpayers
money to release these people quickly
get back to catch release
how about actually enforcing the law it
will cost a lot less
enforced like the trump administration
did and drop illegal immigration 70
percent
there's an easy fix of this reinstate
the remaining mexico program
let the board retreat secure the border
rather than uh acting as tourist
stations letting people
releasing people united states and let
ice do their job let them enforce
immigration laws and interior
because people come across that border
no they're going to be released they
know they're never going to remove
because ice can't remove them because
ice been decapitated
it's until the pride administration
starts taking law enforcement serious
it's not going to stop tom listen to
tyler moran moran
he's a special assistant to president
biden on immigration in the
domestic policy council i'm going to get
your take of this watch
the borders aren't open but we're also
following the law
and the law says that when he people
come to our border
and they ask for protection that we can
process them
not everybody's going to qualify and not
everybody's going to stay
but we're not a country that's going to
turn kids back into the desert by
themselves
just a quick comment from you on that
tom they're seemingly they're not
changing anything
first of all they're not enforcing any
laws she's wrong if these people are
claiming asylum they're not even
conducting asylum interviews
they're they're they're processed and
release them no asylum interviews are
even being conducted
so she don't know what she's talking
about and i'm sick and tired of bite
administration saying the men and women
of borgcho
send people back to the desert to die
men and women and border patrol saved
over 4 000 people
these people were they're being treated
humanely by bullets legends
the only humanity on the southern border
right now is the men and women wearing
green the way they treat these children
and women
no one sent anybody back in the desert
to die and unlike what president biden
said during his speech
no one's sitting there watching children
starving to death on the banks of rio
grande
mine the commander-in-chief for making
such a statement and maybe just a last
question to you um there is a report
that the white house is considering
the possibility of sending direct
payments to people in
central america you know to try to get
them
which is not come what do you think of
that
well we held hostage now we got to pay
people not the violator laws look
you should do that you're going to see
the migrant numbers get higher than than
they are now
because now you're giving them money so
they can pay an alien smuggler to get
them here
it's just ridiculous again you don't
have to spend all this money
let borbacho and ice enforce the law let
barbato secure the border
they did it under the trump
administration they can do it again you
send money to central americans
that's going to be more people smuggled
to the united states because they're
going to turn that money over the
analyst mugglers
tom homan always good to be with you i'm
sure we'll see you again this week thank
you
hey thanks for having me